if you ain't first you last that's what
you should be saying to yourself well
i'm gonna go faster than you're gonna
i'm gonna go 160. no you're not
there guys clint because we are here
today brought to you by the nascar
racing experience here in las vegas and
oh boy am i excited about this video
let's watch it
good morning where we going boys you got
you pulled us all the way to vegas to
have a good time last night i don't
think so something something's afoot
we're gonna go to nascar to get the full
experience
this is pretty exciting what was that
talkers movie days of thunder days of
thunder i'm going to be tom cruise i'm
going to prove to all you guys the
winner of this gets to wear the tom
cruise jacket
nico
finally i get the chance to prove myself
like this is as real as it gets you are
actually driving and racing on a real
nascar track it's gonna feel like an
actual race you have a spotter he's
actually talking to you through a radio
and your earpiece you're just
communicating both ways going around the
track it feels like the real thing
they're not just gonna let you go out
there you get a safety briefing first
they make sure that you know what you're
doing they walk you through all the
steps safety is the number one priority
for everyone here
i get to race too do you guys have your
driver's license as well yes oh my god
i have
god why do you keep doing that your real
piece of work part of the nascar racing
experience is you actually get to dress
up in a full-on suit look at this oh
clinton jones jr that's me i'll be
honest i've never really been that big
into nascar growing up i felt like
the coolest part about nascar was always
like crashes and that's a terrible thing
to say but i mean i think today might
change that what can we expect okay you
will not have anyone in the race car
with you
oh we'll be by ourselves like nascar you
will be timed and it will give you your
highest mile per hour i'm gonna be
getting the highest track times the
highest laptop
i'm gonna go with the try i will destroy
you red i will destroy it
first before we actually drive the cars
themselves we're gonna do a ride-along
meaning that we're going to sit in the
passenger seat as a professional race
car driver drives around the track i'm
kind of scared i'm a little nervous
hi i'm doing all right ready let's do
this
so
[Music]
ah
oh wow
oh boy
that was so fast i'm more scared now
those banks i could feel like my eyelids
my cheeks are going
i felt those g's
just pressing down on my brain i thought
i was gonna be able to handle this no
problem now i've got like pre-drive
jitters i don't know if uh if i can do
that on my own how fast do you think
you're gonna go today like realistically
i'm gonna try and go 150. well i'm going
to go faster than you're going to go i'm
going to go 160. no you're not i'm gonna
go 160. you're not going to go under
166. all right we're going to have
nickel first so that he knows what to
expect when we go
[Music]
next you didn't expect to go first did
you nope nope so you got to get a helmet
dude
yeah
thank you i feel like a medieval peasant
i'm nervously excited i'm just gonna be
relaxed take it easy and get on those
banks dude we're going to the bank
[Music]
nick is off he's actually driving a real
nascar
he was he was going fast something i
didn't realize about these nascars is
that they don't have a speedometer on
the inside they don't care about their
speed they only care about their revs
because that's all that matters is how
much you're pushing that engine it
doesn't matter what speed you're
actually going so i'm gonna time nick
for an actual race if you get anywhere
in the 40-second range that's an amazing
map okay see how fast his lap is
starting right
now
he's coming around
49.5 seconds so we'll see how fast his
next lap is
he just did 24 straight minutes of
driving with eight eight minute
intervals nick those were your fastest
laps dude
nick how was it
that's unlike anything i've ever done
white knuckles dude your fastest time
was 46.9 seconds okay that's pretty fast
i'm next i'm gonna go put my helmet on
i'm gonna try to beat your times i'm
still scared from like the ride along we
did that was intense just commit to the
turn commit to the turns okay you'll be
all right you'll be all right okay i'll
be okay okay all right you'll be fine
so this is like a neck brace right yeah
yep so i can't i can't turn my head it
limits my head movement and forward and
back oh this is it
this is
there it go
oh my god
oh my god
all right
it feels so freaky to see a stairwell
not attached
red radio check all right my name is
daniel i will be your instructor my
boy's been gonna become a man today
let's do this let's go ahead and roll
out 2 000 and he's off the clutch
very good i want you to shift every 3
000 rpm until you're in fourth year
4 000 rpm
am i in the center
uh close enough
they got a spotter he's right below the
las vegas motor speedway side and he's
giving ren directions his rent can't see
he can only see like this much 4200 rpm
4200 straight down the center all right
i'm typing around here he comes
50 seconds
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
oh my god you're right you get
comfortable the first several rounds i
found myself getting like really tense
and then i just had to like let myself
like physically relax like all my
muscles relax i'm like i'm just going
through this turn no big deal just
coming out of it 5000 rpm oh hit the
chip a little bit no big deal keep going
clint you got nothing little do you know
ren we've been timing you man and those
times aren't looking too good
you have to you have to really really
pull through on this on this last what
are my times i'll just say they're not
too hot what are my times what are my
times i gotta know you broke 50 like
once or twice
you you need to step it up man
this is the competitive round now
i have to beat 46 seconds now
[Music]
stronger stronger ish start this time
[Music]
45.72 that's that's really good that's
the best so far
that time i was ready for it i went hard
how'd i do really well yeah
man nick what an experience dude this is
so cool this is not a race guys this is
about personal best it's getting the
best lap time
you know except when you pair those
personal bests together then it's a
competition and that's what this is
today between the three of us so oh man
i'm ready i'm super ready
dang this is crazy imagine this was your
daily commute to the last round i'm just
gonna stay real chill if you ain't first
you last that's that's what that's what
you should be saying to yourself
[Music]
all right
and the clock is ticking
will clint beat my record time
51 seconds he's got to pick it up
[Music]
[Music]
that was 45.56 that was his best lap yet
did i win
i feel like a new man well clint i will
say that you did pretty well
and i don't feel comfortable giving you
your charm just here
there's so much huge air in how fast i
can hit a button okay we got to look at
the speed sheets see who really won
let's get to the speed sheet my top
speed is
156.89 miles an hour that is fast that's
the fastest i've ever gone and then i
came close i was
156.23 oh my gosh that's within that's
within like what is that 0.6.66
oh dude that was close dude you beat me
by two-thirds of a mile an hour how
about you nick 125. you were 155. it was
a good race though it was a very good
race it was a good race we were all
within a mile an hour of each other that
was pretty crazy
well you guys are back that was
incredible what a ride
that was so good oh my god you guys 156
miles an hour it was like on a nascar
trail
to the track like you're going sideways
like
we're nascar drivers now i thought you
guys were hating on nascar no dude dude
i'm all about nascar now i'm gonna watch
the next race it's like i am so
interested in this stuff now i think the
coolest part is that you guys can do the
same thing as well actually now is the
best time to do it because there's a 50
off sale for the holidays
yeah right now 50 but that's not all or
also did you guys know you could save an
extra 5
by going to the website nascar racing
experience
corridor crew use the coupon code below
in our description so that's 50 off for
the holidays plus another five percent
that's another this is the best time to
do it guys seriously get yourselves in
there go for it let it go oh you don't
even have to go to vegas you can go to
like almost any sort of master location
all the major locations have this
experience they're gonna be here next
week yeah talladega daytona any of the
big racing centers it's no longer the
quarter crew it's the pit crew would you
rather fight one horse-sized duck or a
hundred duck-sized horses we're doing
that video we've been giving two scoops
for two videos scripts to shoot this
week yeah scripts and a shot let's sign
somebody suggested shooting this by
wednesday but i don't know on wednesday
might be a little empty wednesday's too
ambitious
i done broke my neck